hey spencer ackerman here with danger
room and the thing that I'm holding you
might think as a smartphone but it isn't
the army calls this an end user device
and it's the latest iteration of a
program that it's been working on for
about twenty years called net warrior
which seeks to solve a really basic
problem for soldiers which is how does
soldiers who are out of their vehicles
communicate data to one another in war
zones in hotspots when things are at
their their most important and if you
look at this end user device right now
this is running on a on a Motorola Atrix
I've got a map that's you know familiar
to any of us with our smartphones it
looks a little bit like what we might
get from from Google Earth and if you
see this blue Chevron I'll pinch it a
little that's my position and some of
these other ones these blue icons note a
little closer those are friendly
positions whether if I'm perhaps the
company commander these are my platoon
and squad leaders I've got everyone
else's positions some of these icons
like for instance let's say this one
right here maybe that's a an area like a
building that I need to clear might have
some enemy in it but it's got more than
just this mapping function if I tap this
I'm going to a menu and I can see some
of the other useful applications that
net warrior contains like for instance
I've got a medivac application
so I'm getting a position I hit next and
right now I've got my frequency I've got
my callsign I go through this and I can
say is this urgent yes this is pretty
urgent and I can go next she was who's
getting out of here
maybe this is more than one person I'm
sending this information out right now
so say new information comes in on a
plan will go to collab planner what we
do here is we're essentially taking new
information and mapping it drawing it
out on the device so that when we send
it out other members of the team can see
it so I'm gonna take this red stylus and
I'm going to draw a route with my finger
that then shows as I'm connecting it
where other members of the team ought to
go so that I've got that that I can hit
Send I name the plan I'm going to name
this wired it done and now wired has
created its own battlefield plan and
I've just saved out and so that's one of
the things you can do with with mad
warrior